hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my game of thrones Westworld
crossover video George R Martin was calling
for it and it was a big twist during the Westworld
finale to this can be an explanation for how
that would work and what would go down if
you haven't been watching Westworld.
There's the idea that it is a themepark a
very big theme park.
But just like Disneyland has a Star Wars land
that has other parks like Epcot Center Westworld
on the TV show has multiple parks Westworld
is just the name of one of the parks.
So game of thrones land like medieval world
in the original Westworld movie would just
be a separate park just a quick reminder there
is new round of the game of thrones giveaway.
All you have to do to enters be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss out on anything during the off-season,
so there couple complications to doing a game
of thrones Westworld crossover because Westworld
is a story all about hosts achieving consciousness.
The robots become self-aware and they rebel.
So there are really two types of stories that
you could do with the game of thrones Westworld
crossover one it could be a story about how
all these characters in season eight after
they finally defeat the white walkers and
end the threat of a second, long night wake
up to the fact that there really robots on
a loop break it and then break out of the
park.
So when we think about the world of Game of
thrones planet tows is kind of like the unofficial
name for it, you have to localize it to a
certain part of the world of Game of thrones
so it had to like just take place in west
roast.
The only real way around that to do like an
entirely self-contained game of thrones Westworld
type story would be to have it set on Mars.
There was a lot of theories during Westworld
this season that it might be set on March
because the park itself is so big, but that
is just one of the questions that they haven't
answered on Westworld yet of the other big
problem.
You know number two is that how he would address
the changing time periods on game of thrones
because a song of ice and fire is this big
saga goes all the way back thousands of years
into the history of the world of planet tows.
So the way they deal with this on Westworld
is that they change people's narratives all
the time the host have like a set loop that
they're on.
They have certain responses that their program
to give people based on input that they get
like if you walk up and say hello the program
to greet you if you do something the tries
to throw them off their loop.
They have some defense mechanisms built into
their programming that keeps them from glitching
out now obviously of the Westworld TV shows
all about them breaking that loop, but if
are going to do game of thrones and we have
like Daenerys we have Jon snow hosts, let's
assume they don't break their loop.
So he walked to Jon Snow in tried to tell
him that he's the son of Leona Stark and radar
Targaryen at the beginning of his loop.
He might not believe you like he would just
be like that doesn't make any sense you would
have to take him along the full loop to show
them the evidence to see the story play out,
but what you could do if you wanted to see
Robert's rebellion is that the people that
were running the game of thrones park like
the Westworld people yet.
Imagine that they're running a game of thrones
park by itself, but separate from the Westworld
Park is that they could change all the host's
narratives use the same host like use the
Daenerys that Jon Snow host and just make
them their ancestors.
So you could do historical storylines like
a guns conquest of the seven kingdoms with
the nearest would have to be written as one
of Aegon sister wives.
So like she would look like Daenerys that
she would be thinking and acting like one
of the sister wives.
So the Westworld Park always has like an entry
point that it brings all the guests the further
you travel out from that kind of home-based
place, the crazier the story gets the more
dangerous it gets.
So what you would have to do is you have to
bring all the guests into King's Landing.
That would be like the place with a really
safe really based stories were people could
go to the horror house, but the people that
wanted the more dangerous story could travel
to the frozen north the edge of the park would
be like the lands of boys winter see you can
actually do white walkers stuff but it would
be like at the very edge of the park.
So the other problem to is that Daenerys doesn't
get her dragons till much much later in the
story so everyone will want to be able to
ride a dragon that be a lot of fun to write
a Dragon host but will you have to do is you
have to compress the game of thrones story.
So imagine game of thrones season one when
Ned Stark brings his family to King's Landing.
You have all those characters all near the
same place you have to bring Daenerys to say
like Dragon stone at that same time.
When really.
At that point in the story.
She hasn't had her dragons yet she still hasn't
got married to Khal Drogo.
So you not to shoehorn and a lot of plot to
a relatively small amount of time just to
make it all work together but that way you
can have Daenerys strafe King's Landing every
once in a while but for the most part the
hosts are designed to be on a one day loop.
So you really only get is much as you can
do in one day of story which means that you
have to be really picky about the one day
that you do like you could do the day of Blackwater,
so that Stannis attacks Tyrion unleashes the
wildfire like this is big battle yet to defend
the red keep, but elsewhere up in the river
lands you have to do war of the five King
stuff if you were to travel to Harrenhal,
you could do tourney of Heron Hall with radar
Targaryen Lyanna Stark night of the laughing
tree, but it would really require you to compress
all those events that in the story of a song
of ice and fire are happening during very
different time periods, but in the park that
is game of thrones land inside Westworld would
all be happening at the same time.
It just that geographically they would be
very far apart, so they wouldn't overlap that
much but travel in Westworld is done via train,
so they have to find a way around that in
game of thrones land like horses only move
so fast.
So people always joke about little fingers
mass rapid transit system like he gets all
the way from the veil up to the north super
quickly vers is able to travel very quickly.
So the only way to travel extremely fast would
be on Dragon back so that would also require
some shoehorning because there only three
dragons and they have to start their loop
at 1 Specific Pl. like a Dragon, stone, you
guys can let me know how would you want them
to do a game of thrones land inside the world
of Westworld.
They would definitely have to make the world
smaller if they did it as a direct crossover
like it's at the end of Westworld the just
going to a different room and you see like
a Daenerys looking host and you're like oh
my God there is a game of thrones land you
have to be a set up like the samurai world
on Westworld where they're just testing it
out.
They haven't opened it to the public yet so
you have to imagine that a lot of the game
of thrones story that we've seen is just the
host like it would be the Westworld people
just testing out that park before they opened
it to the public, because then you get like
all the regular people coming in trying to
throw host off their loop like people trying
to get help from Ned Stark to pull him off
his loop, maybe he doesn't get beheaded, but
there's always some big twist someone with
a secret agenda at the top like the Delos
Corporation people that actually own the park
then you have the Robert Ford character that
has his own agenda who's trying to free the
hosts allow them to attain consciousness do
you have to find a way to write in George
RR Martin himself to the story where he's
trying to free all of these game of thrones
hosts.
So in the game of thrones land scenario George
RR Martin is the Robert Ford character being
pushed out by the Delos Corporation which
would be like the HBO executives in this case
because the fun thing about the Westworld
TV show is that it's also kind of a metaphor
about making television like you try to make
this narrative, but you have all these executive
external forces trying to make money off the
show while you the creator are just trying
to tell this amazing story.
So that's what you have to appreciate HBO
in real life with this Westworld TV show because
they're so cool with being satirized in that
way I think they don't mind as long as it's
really good television like they really just
want to hit show that everybody wants to see
Bliss fancast it.
So Dolores would probably be the Daenerys
character, meaning that Teddy would be Jon
Snow and obvious.
I think that the man in black would have to
be little finger the person who feels like
the world belongs to him, but isn't destined
to be there seems like he wants to help everyone
when really he just wants it for himself.
Let me know in the comments though how crazy
would you go if they made a real life game
of thrones theme park for a long ways away
from that level of technology but I was the
I'll be doing Westworld game of thrones bonus
videos in the off-season game of thrones,
even though it's taking a long time to get
here will get here a lot faster than Westworld
season two but congratulations to this week's
game of thrones giveaway winner Inc. panther
you and a $20 Amazon gift card please private
message me on the back and my channel so I
can get your contact details.
There is a new round that started now so I'll
just remind people when I post my next Westworld
in game of thrones videos, but is all kinds
a midseason finale's happening tonight.
So my next video will be the flash midseason
finale while you guys wait for that to post
you can click here for my Westworld finale
video is little bit about season two and you
can click here for my breakdown of that game
of thrones teaser the just drop.
Thank you so much watching everybody high
five I'll see you guys tonight!